[Música]
más
y
[Música]
mujer o a mí tienen la goma
es en nuestro saludo
le digo un saludo queridos amigos
quiero agradecer la oportunidad que me
dan los organizadores de este evento tan
hermoso y poder contarles aunque sea una
mínima parte de sobre la cultura china
por qué
es valioso que se recuerde
panamá va la madre naturaleza la madre
tierra porque sabía que dice
había nacido porque se dio cuando en su
como visión se lo enseño
y toda la mañana del hombre con mucho
respeto
el principal de cada una de las casas
elevadas humanos
y decía esta oración a la madre tierra
de algo
[Música]
y segunda
y finley
que no me castigue madre tierra porque
voy a tomar de ti lo que necesite para
mí para mi familia
a ccoo el etic sin lastimar
innecesariamente a tus hijos ni a
ninguno de los
también se refiere a los animales ya que
cuando el dios los creó le dijo que
respete a los otros animales
está diciendo ustedes también sean
animales
tienen derecho a servirse de ello y
alimentarse ellos también tienen el
mismo derecho y deben ser respetados y
cuidados nunca de nada
vamos a tomar asiento y vamos a iniciar
una entrevista si con blas
primero te quiero hacer una consulta
quiero saber por qué el pueblo chino es
un pueblo realmente agradecido y
generoso y nos gustaría que nos cuentes
la historia de generoso
porque así que todo es un hombre
como su nombre lo dice su nombre es muy
generoso de prendidos y preocupado por
la necesidad de la gente más que la
propia él siempre vivía ayudando a toda
vez que necesitaban
en la construcción de la embarcación y
personal no todos tenían la habilidad y
la capacidad de hacerlo el agua se
quedaba sin pedir nada a cambio a las
personas que necesitaban los pescadores
o cualquier familia quieren estar
cuando un día
una parte de la historia que me conmovió
mucho que era como él
sacrificó su vida llevando agua en un
momento muy trágico de otros pueblos y
después de vivir
sembrando cosechando repartiendo todos
principalmente conocer los ancianos de
la mujer que cada un sobre con sus niños
como en tiempo de paz él siempre estaba
sembrando y cosechando distintas cosas
por eso formaba pueblo era el único
pueblo virgen que deformaba pueblos ya
que por ser agricultor necesitaba cuidar
de sus sembradíos y
levantar las cosechas y aprovecharlas y
guardar guardaban también muchos
alimentos
lo importante es que el tiempo de guerra
siempre con sus hijos y su esposo y sus
hijas ya que era un pueblo de guerrero
luchaba defendiendo a su pueblo
cuando vieron incendio
inundación lo que fuera
winter es un incendio
a través de la inundación siempre estaba
ayudando sirviendo a todos pero llegó
una época en la zona muy difícil porque
llegó la langosta
y junto con sequía muy prolongada
cristiana siempre tenía reserva de
alimentos que guardaba en sus depósitos
ganan ti
así el tipo palafito
depósitos y siempre tenía alimentos de
mar bien a la orilla del río y en la
fila guay ps nunca le faltaba no sé que
no pasaba necesidades pero voy a hacer
acá un pueblo de ua
la sombra pegada porque era un pueblo
que siempre seguía el externa porque era
un pueblo de servicio de esso pero la
regla del pueblo y tena no permitían que
compartían sus alimentos
en caso de extrema necesidad con los
vecinos porque yo no sabía en guardar no
no eran industriosos para guardarlo la
comida que necesitaban entren a casa
animales vivo con lazos con poso y lo
iba a guardar de correr y con un citaba
no mataba
así que el pueblo en biguá empezó a
pasar necesidades
generoso se sintió obligado a ayudarle
[Música]
estuvo muchos días cargando les agua ya
que ellos no tenían acceso al agua su
salud y su regula estaban secas
y luego tuvo que empezar a cavar pozos
para enterrarlo cuando a medida que iba
muriendo
aborigen lengua
su vida se agotó y terminó muerto del
costado del camino que rendón el agua
si el consejo superior del pueblo tener
para honrar le dio el nombre de usted
qué
se llama así en la cultura eterna que la
palabra que significa antiguo
el robot
milenario y en toda la tierra conocido y
utilizado como
es muy generoso por eso le dieron el
nombre al aro por la similitud con trato
el señor que era del linaje superior de
los que gobernaban los pueblos ya nada
ese ejemplo de esforzarse tanto a tratar
su vida y hacer que su familia también
trabaje para qué tratando de salvar a un
pueblo que no era de su sangre
y por qué es tan generoso
y yo lo hizo así en la sombra no
funcionó
a las aves de alimento en su vaina
madera cuando seca luego en sus raíces y
lo acaban de llegar
bastante profundas raíces tiene un
depósito de agua que es utilizado por
los aborígenes en épocas de grandes
sequía
en los montes donde está lejos del agua
saben que se calman las raíces siempre
van a encontrar agua la tintura en los
tejidos
puede han tenido para pintarse si quiere
pintarse
y data una medicina muy importante para
nuestra que era
para mitigar la ceguera o la opacidad
del cristalino lo sabemos ahora en los
ojos de los ancianos corte las ramas
verde
del agarró la calienta al fuego y la
inclina y empieza a accionar
un líquido marrón espumoso y con eso el
curandero de limpiado a los ojos los
ancianos que mejoraban mucho la vista
por eso es un nuevo muy respetado muy
apreciado que daiana respetaba a todos
los árboles porque cuando necesitaba
cortar uno para ello es un ser vivo como
debe ser para nosotros como en realidad
es un ser que hoy se piensa y razona
pero de otra otra forma de vida
ahí me despierta otra pregunta que es
respetaban tanto en la naturaleza
respetan tanto la naturaleza el pueblo
chana que como hacen en caso de
necesitar un árbol vivo cómo hacen para
aprovechar de él
primero como cuando hace la oración del
amanecer le pide a la madre tierra que
no lo castigue porque vamos a tener uno
de sus hijos ya que los hago en el
idioma nativo de al lado o sea hijo de
la madre tierra
[Música]
pide que no lo castigue y le explica
para que lo necesita para hacer canoa
principalmente y que con la rama
cocinera su comida que no desperdiciarán
a de largo entonces luego toda la
familia que necesita la canoa o hacer su
casa lo que sea
y escarbó acaban la raíz e hasta qué
el árbol solos en clínicas y recién
después de dos días que está el árbol
caído que lo consideran como muerto lo
empiezan a trabajar
hacer lo que sea menester
pero juntos respeto hacia la madre
tierra y hacia el árbol
bueno te invito a pararte porque yo creo
que es un momento para que puedas a
todos los que nos están escuchando los
que nos están viendo darles un mensaje
un mensaje que venga del pueblo china
como pueblo está nada un pueblo muy
generoso
sin maldad
a pesar de ser muy bravo guerreros en
todas las mujeres como lugar ones para
un pueblo sin egoísmo todo lo compartía
todo era trueque
no había necesidad de que los abuelos
ande pidiendo nada ni dice había persona
abandonada con rabbani respetaba a la
mujer el anciano y el niño al niño ni
siquiera se lo maltrata
yo tengo hijo abuelo y con la escuela
todavía pero gracias a dios ninguno
jamás se me había ocurrido levantar la
mano y decirle una palabra injuriosa que
lo lastimé o que lo ofenda
y sigue así esa es la enseñanza que
recibimos respetaban a todo y ese
respeto mutuo hizo que se mantuvieran
por tanto miles de años acá ya que este
vino por lo que se ha comprobado por los
registros de los antropólogos en nogoyá
donde vivíamos nosotros mi familia vivió
más de 2000 años quizás 2.500 o más
bueno ellos respetaban tanto a la
persona como a la naturaleza ya que
cuando se fueron de ese lugar porque con
bueno no aplicar porque era un blanco lo
hicieron salir pero tenemos que
abandonar sus tierras
y dejaron los ríos limpios los arroyos
limpios como estaban yo recuerdo cuando
niño todavía alcancé a conocer algunos
arroyos escondidos en los montes que no
podía ver los peces experto del fondo
límpido
en lo que son
el río la bolsa de polipropileno basura
todo lo que se puede tirar se tira en el
río como que fuera la basura y la sangre
de la madre tierra para eliana de la
abuela son las venas de hacerte de la
madre tierra por eso ron rabah también y
respetaba
queremos despedirnos y agradecerles
entonces este momento y poder cuidar de
la naturaleza
vamos a hacer la despedida al estilo del
pueblo llenar nuestro despedida es como
una bendición
dijo en el ojo igual y está ahí
chila
que el dios de los tiana les bendiga en
sus caminos
que puedan crear bien a sus hijos de los
hijos para que puedan honrar a sus
padres
con todo respeto a su madre por supuesto
es decir padres 12
para que traten de ser felices ya que el
fin con el que venimos a esta tierra
creemos otra parte ese aprobado
es de progresar y de ser felices jesús
dice
el hombre existe para que tenga gozo en
hombre y la mujer por supuesto entonces
es nuestra despedida y nuestra bendición
que el señor dijo en el nuestro dios
bendiga gracias
[Aplausos]